[Music]
what is it like being convicted for a
murder that now this judge
says
she didn't do
more than any other word jubilant
you know thank god he came along guilty
on 8 news now i-team exclusive for the
first time since the judge overturned
her murder conviction margaret rudin is
talking about what's next she was dubbed
the black widow convicted of killing her
husband in the 1990s then last month a
federal judge said there was not enough
evidence to send her to prison and that
her lawyer was ineffective the 8 news
now i-team's david charns here now with
ruden's first interview since that judge
sent her free brian denise the state had
a month to appeal this federal judge's
ruling and the state deciding not to
retry margaret rudin the clock
officially running out in this infamous
murder case now margaret rudin is
talking about what's next
why do you want to talk about all this
you know why
because i'm 79. margaret rudin says the
justice system stole 20 of those 79
years two decades she spent in prison
for a murder a federal judge now says
she didn't commit it's not about the
truth it's about who has the better
attorney we find the defendant
guilty in 2001 a jury convicted rudin
for the death of her husband ron his
charred body found near lake mohave in
1994 a month after he disappeared from
the couple's home what do you remember
from
december of 1994
when your husband disappeared he had
always cheated
and every time he would say i'm not
going to do it again i'm not going to do
it again in a 10-week long trial she was
dubbed the black widow painted as a wife
out to get her husband's money what do
you think of that moniker i don't think
anybody would dare call me that to my
face prosecutors alleging margaret shot
ron while he slept but the federal judge
finding there was no evidence linking
her to the murder weapon to ron's
abandoned car or to a crime scene they
didn't have enough evidence that it
could have
affected yes she could have done it or
yes somebody could have come in the
judge also finding rudin's attorney
michael amador who is now deceased
didn't do enough to defend her saying he
was more interested in fame than a
ruling in his client's favor
he was
expecting
that he was going to rise
to fame you know make a lot of money off
my case after 20 years in prison the
parole board granted her release what
were those 20 years in prison like if
you have to go to prison
make sure you're middle aged to beyond
because the girls do treat you much
nicer
you know lie was a lot of the girl's
mother last month the judge issuing his
order to vacate rudin's conviction and
scrub her record now with plans to move
out of las vegas she hopes to write
books about the trial and her time in
prison everything is broken down by year
and every one of them is going to be a
book moving forward she says she wants
to help other people specifically women
in prison she says her faith is telling
her everything happens for a reason it
didn't make me better it didn't
there were times like
i didn't think i'd live through it
but i don't think i'm
cynical i'm not bitter
the judge also writing about potential
other suspects in this murder case
including people after ron rudin's
wealth and investors in his businesses
margaret rudin says she is dating a new
man and they plan to move away out of
las vegas together i'm david charns live
local now